Amnesia is a real thing.
Now all we need is scientific evidence of
evil twins and life will be just like a CW
show.
Anthony here for Dnews and Michael Boatwright
woke up in Palm Springs at the Desert Regional
Medical Center speaking Swedish and convinced
his name was Johan Ek.
According to the Desert Sun, the 61-year-old
man said the reflection in the mirror wasn't
him and he couldn't remember any details of
his life.
A little digging revealed him to be a Navy
vet and graphic designer who spent some time
teaching English abroad, though not in Sweden.
Though a little more digging did find him
dressed as a knight and using a Swedish name
on some message boards.
That is true.
This is some legit soap opera craziness, guys.
What is going on here?
It's called transient global amnesia and it's
considered a fugue state.
If you watch Breaking Bad, you've probably
heard that term before.
A fugue state is basically caused by some
sort of intense mental trauma and it causes
memory loss, identity confusion, and sudden
and unplanned travel.
People suffering from it can carry on normal
conversations, they're not physically impaired.
It's only when someone asked them a question
about themselves that they realize they don't
know who they are.
What's interesting is that we're not really
sure what the underlying causes of fugue states
are, neurologically.
We do know that TGA sufferers seem to have
a history of migraines and are usually over
50.
Mild head trauma can cause one, high stress
levels sudden immersion in hot or cold water,
alcohol abuse, even sexual intercourse.
Sex so good or bad that you literally forget
who you are.
That's pretty nuts.
Transient global amnesia tends to last only
a day but fugue states can last a few months.
Now Boatwright reportedly had his symptoms
since February 28, which make doctors think
he's suffering from some combination of the
two, or a new type of fugue state entirely.
Or maybe he's a faker.
People do that a lot too to to escape criminal
or financial trouble.
But there are about twenty four legitimate
cases of this reported every year.
Now the good news is that whether long or
short term, fugue states tend to go away on
their own.
There's no medication to speed the process
along because no one's ever pinpointed a direct
neurological cause for them.
But some patients show some underlying brain
damage that might have existed for a while.
Doctors have had luck speeding recovery along
with things like art therapy and counseling.
The real danger is that people who suffer
from fugue states can have larger disassociated
disorders later on in life.
Things like dementia.
So it's really important that they work with
doctors and therapists afterwards to stay
in good mental shape.
How crazy fascinating is this?
People have lost their entire idea who they
are by being dumped in cold water.
I am hoping that they're doing some serious
observation on this guy because I would love
it if they could get a better idea of what
causes all this stuff.
You can check out everything we know about
Michael Boatwright down below and subscribe
for more Dnews.